ladies and gentlemen I have just found  out that Angela Bassett has won the  Golden Globe Award for best supporting  actress in Black Panther wakander  forever which is cool cool for Marvel  great for Marvel because I believe she  is the very first performer out of the  MCU to win a Golden Globe first one to  win such a prestigious award will she  get an Oscar nomination because she's  damn well better I think she absolutely  deserves it because yeah I'm thrilled  for her thrilled for her like many other  people we said in our review that she  deserves to be Oscar nominated for this  role so I am so thrilled that she  actually won for the Golden Globe  because she is powerful in the film so  vulnerable such a poignant performance  so personal  I think it's a great great win fantastic  win happy for you Angela Bassett you you  freaking served it